seventh heaven like all the photo play
winners received the award because it
was a popular success photoplays of fan
magazine and fans would write in letters
they would write in they would follow
their stars and in some cases they would
also follow directors a film like 7th
heaven had huge advance word of mouth
because it was such a popular stage play
so people were waiting for 7th heaven
and actually it's a tribute to the
direction and the actors and the
realization of the film that it was able
to meet the audience's expectations and
do such a good job I heaven to see
newsreel footage from the Fox outtake
collection at University of South
Carolina that shows Frank boards Iggy
and his brother Luo bores Aggie on board
a ship about to set sail for Paris
France to do research for 7th heaven
supposedly the studio more or less had
to send them on vacation because 7th
heaven was supposed to be shot before
sunrise but as soon as Mona was brought
in it was such a big deal for the studio
that pretty much everything was put
aside for sunrise so Franken Lou got a
wonderful sea cruise and in the newsreel
footage you can see one shot where
they're supposed to be there pretending
they're working on the script for 7th
heaven and the wind is blowing and you
can see script pages turning and Frank
is smiling to the camera talking to Lou
and that's them working then there are
other shots where you see them playing
shuffleboard on deck and you see them
you know just basically enjoying
themselves it was right time right place
as far as Fox and Myrna were concerned
and their personalities obviously hit it
off and so Fox said I want a genius
you're it the last laugh is the best
film I ever saw in my life will you make
a masterpiece for me at Fox and we're
now said yeah William Fox knowing that
sunrise had not made money like he
wanted or especially like his underling
Winfield she hadn't wanted he let people
like Frank boards
a John Ford Raoul Walsh make films in
the style of more now in their own way
it's not like they were copycatting were
now but they were using similar things
and they were they had all watched him
every all the crews had watched him
everybody was trying to figure out why
he was doing what he was doing and what
he was doing so therefore that that in
my view earns William Fox the Oscar of
all Oscars you know that he was really
prescient he really was looking ahead
toward what can cinema be in a way that
studio heads warrant and it's our great
loss that you know he lost his studio
you